よろしくお願いします
では早速話に入りますけど
今日のテーマはそれほど難しいテーマではございませんと思います
大体我々 私はいろいろ厳しい言葉とかね
言ったりしますから
そこら辺ちょっと鍵かけられています
この私は言いたいところはだいたいこの前にもっと丁寧な文章で読み上げられたので
そこら辺は一応省いていただけます
仏教って何なのかというと
心の安らぎをまず説くんですね
それから究極的な幸福というものは説いています
決してこの仏教は嫌いだ
嫌いだ 嫌だとかね 思っているのはこの世の中の普通の思考なんですけど
それも誤解の結果で 間違いの結果で
誤解するんだったら
間違いするんだったらとことん間違ってやるぞという感じで
徹底的に仏教を間違って理解しているんですね
すごい暗い考え方だと
社会に対しては迷惑だと
発展には発展を妨げているんだとかね
それは 日本だけではなくて
他のいろんな もう特に西洋の世界で
もうかなりそういう風に学者の間では批判されてきたものなんですね
そういうことで
このいろいろ他宗教の方々も
仏教の国々で伝道活動するときでも
その武器を持って あんた方はもう世界は否定しているんだ
生きていることは否定しているんだ
ですから 社会の発展に対しては迷惑だと
生きていることは「苦」だと思ったら
どうにもならないのではないかと
そういうふうな批判もあります
それはすべてが読み違いなんですよ
とにかく欠点を見ようという気持ちで
批判してみようという気持ちで読んで
適当なところで 1行2行取って
それから言いたい放題のことを語っちゃうだけなんですね
ですから ちゃんと証拠を出して語っているわけでもないんです
だからはっきりとお釈迦様が自分が何をおっしゃってますかと
はっきりと明言しています
人間の悩み 苦しみをなくすための道を説いているんだと
憂い 悲しみをなくすための道を説いているんだと
智慧の開発のための道を説いているんだと
心の平安 安らぎ 解脱を体験するための道であると
だからお釈迦様の教えはそういう道であって
それがはっきりと一番古い経典の一番古い層のストレータというか
そこら辺に入っているのにも関わらず
一応仏教っていうのは暗い教えだなというふうに
その考え方は断固と消そうとはしないんですね
ですから 私もこういうところで
ものすごい激しく そこら辺はもうポイントをね
徹底的に言ってますけど
それでも人生も生き方も何でも暗く見るという傾向はなかなか治らないんですね
修行を実践してみても
人生は明るくなくなるところか
もうさらに落ち込んで小さく狭くなるような傾向も見えるんですよ
そこは もしかすると
その固定概念はとても大事にありがたく思っているからかもしれませんね
ですから まず一番最初に冒頭として言いたいのは
ブッダの教えは幸福の教えであると
安らぎの教えであるということなんですね
心の平安 心の安らぎ そのための教えなんです
皆様方はよくお読みになっていらっしゃると思いますけど
四念処経 大四念処経は始まるのも
この悩み苦しみをなくすために
憂い悲しみをなくすために
一つの道しかありませんと
ですから その場合もはっきりしていますよ
ブッダは幸福を語っている人だということは
安らぎを語っている人だということはよくわかると思います
そこで私はずいぶん自慢するところがございまして
それは人類の歴史上 初めに現れた世界宗教はブッダの教えなんですよ
今 世界宗教というのはものすごいたくさんありますけど
仏教というのはすごい小さくて
もう誰も信じてくれない
バカにされるようになってますけど
世界で初めて 人類の史上初めて
この世界宗教というのを作ったのはお釈迦様なんです
それはどういうことかと
宗教学的に考えるとお分かりになると思いますけど
世の中に実際に今まであるいろんなたくさんの宗教がございまして
すごい古い このもうゼンド・アヴェスター(ゾロアスター教の聖典)とかね
信仰しているこの元イラン人
イラン人の元の宗教 ゾロアスター教とかね
それから時代的に少々遅れているインドにあるバラモン教
ヒンドゥ教とかね また歴史すごい古い
ユダヤ系統のね その旧約聖書に基づいて頑張っているね その教えとか
それから新しい時代に現れたイエス様の新約聖書に基づいているキリスト教とかね
それから中国でも宗教的な思考が確かにありましたんでしょうし
老子やら孔子とかね 孟子とか
そういう方々の宗教というふうにあんまり言いづらいかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり結局は経済学でもなくて
政治学でもないんだから
生き方を教えているんだから
やっぱり宗教にした方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
それからインドで皆様あまり知られていないし
インド以外 インド国以外は出ていてない
もう一つの大変 哲学的にはなかなかできている宗教がございます
ジャイナ教というね その宗教もお釈迦様より古いんですね
それから一番最近現れたのはイスラム教なんですね
その諸々の宗教の中
ちょっと観察してみると
この国際性というのは乏しいと思いますよ
なぜかというと 例えばヒンドゥー教というのはカースト制度がございまして
このカースト制度というのはインド社会のシステムなんですよ
神様がバラモン人をまず作って
それからヴァイシャ シュードラ
クシャトリヤ　ヴァイシャ　シュードラという４つのカーストを作って
それが人類ですよと そういうふうに言った途端
それがインド人の宗教になるんであって
日本人の宗教ではなくなっちゃうんですね
だって日本では一人のバラモン人もいないし
クシャトリヤ族もヴァイシャ族ももうなかなかいないんだから
中国人の宗教でもなくなっちゃうんですよ
そこでその元バラモン教
今のヒンドゥー教 その中にあるしきたり
習慣 儀式 儀礼 すべて見ると
やっぱりこのカーストやらインド人の文化とかね
それは激しく効くんですよ
それでなんでヒンドゥー教は世界で知られているようになったかというと
ウパニシャッドの思想なんですよ
ウパニシャッドはもう一応哲学を語ろうと努力しましたから
その点で なんですよ ですから
徹底的に初めから国際宗教ということではないし
ユダヤ教はどうでしょうかといえば
はっきりわかっている
それはユダヤ人の宗教であって
イエス様ももうあちこちでやっぱり民族主義的なことを喋ったりもするし
愛というね 無制限の愛を語ってはいらっしゃいますけど
もしかするとユダヤ文化からね
責められちゃって いろいろそこら辺はセンサーシップ（検閲）っていうかね
制限された可能性もありますね
言葉を もしかすると その方がね
もうものすごい革命的で
人類に対する限りない愛を語りたかったかもしれませんが
聖書の中ではなかなかそこら辺はもう削除されているか
言わせなかったか どちらかでしょうし
イスラム教にしたっても
ものすごい民族主義なんですよ
もう万人に共通という風にはなかなか見えないんですね
その性格っていうのは
それから中国の
老子の思想やら そういうものはやっぱり中国人の特色の思想になってしまって
老子の教えはなかなかね
立派なもので すごい普遍性と哲学性はありますけど
結局 孔子の教えやらね
道教やらね そういうものはやっぱり中国的なものなんですね
では 日本の伝統的なね
すごい古い宗教である神道って何でしょうかという
それは日本人だけの宗教なんですよ
外国に教えることはできません
言ったっても笑っちゃうと思いますよ
伊勢神宮をお参りしましょうと言ってもね
外国人にとっては別に何の興味も何のこともないんでしょうに
でお釈迦様は初めて人類には差別はないんだと
人類は一色だよと お釈迦様は他の生命と比べるんですよ
もうカラスと犬は違う
動物と人間は違う でも人間の間で何が違いますかと
全く何もないでしょうと
ですから人類はもう一つですよと
一色ですよと 一種ですよと
それで語った言葉の中で
一言葉も民族性っていうのはないんです
人々のために そういうふうに語ったんですよ
人類のために それだけじゃないんですよ
次元はもっと広いんです
お釈迦様おっしゃるの
この教えが人間だけではなくて
人間よりみんな拝んでいる
尊敬している 怯えている神々であろうとも
これ勉強してみなさいと
これが真理だよと ですから
神々でも自分の心を救われたいと
安らぎを味わいたいと
苦しみたくないと思うならば
ブッダの教えを実践するしか方法はないと
それぐらい大胆に語っているんですよ
それでお釈迦様が人ぐらいの悟った方々ができたところで
みんなあっちこっち歩いてくださいと
二人で行くなよという解釈もありますし
二人で行けという解釈もあるし
どちらでもいいんですけど
一応60人だから 一人で一人で行ってくださいと
インドは広大な国だから
歩いて この ādikalyāṇaṃ majjhekalyāṇaṃ pariyosānakalyāṇaṃ という法を説いてくださいと
初めも大変素晴らしい
美しい教えである この悲観的な教えではないんです
エクセレントという kalyāṇa ということを英語で訳すればね
エクセレント ナイス という意味なんですね
ですから この何といいます
この初めから初めも美しい
教えの真ん中のところも美しい
終点も 終わりも美しいんだと
その美しい教えを教えてくださいと
Caratha bhikkhave cārikaṃ
それからbahujanahitāya
大勢の人々のために 幸福のために
bahujanasukhāya 幸せのために
atthāya 意味のあるもの
atthāya sukhāya hitāya
deva manussānaṃ
人類と神々の幸福の幸せのために
意味のあるこの教えを広げてみなさいよと
なんでそんなことをしたんですかって？大きな宗教組織作りたいではなくて
お釈迦様にあった この無量の慈しみなんですね
その慈しみに基づいてみんな苦しんでいるんだ
みんな悩んでいるんだ
みんなもう道がわからなくて
幸福の道がどこにあるかとわからなくて もがいているんだと
ですから歩きなさいよと
それで何もものを持たない比丘サンガを設定したんです
比丘サンガの唯一の目的は
仏教を語って歩き回ることなんです
それに褒めてもらわなくたっても
決して仏教を語る人々はもう全然それで機嫌が悪くなることでもないんです
逆に聞いてくれたら それはすごくありがたい
感謝する 聞いてもらわなかったんだからといって
別にご褒美狙ってやっているわけでもないし
それはあまり気にしない
反論すると機嫌が悪くなることは全くない
反論するのは当たり前であって
思考は違っているんだから 違う思考だから
反論すると できるだけ親切に丁寧に答えようとする
だからって 仏教のお坊さんたちというのは
すごくもうぐにゃぐにゃ性格で
みんなにも言われたい放題言われるかというと
それはそうじゃないんです
真理を語っているんだから
すごいまっすぐ語る 人が単なる反論のために
ただ面白おかしく遊びたいだけのために反論しちゃうと
その場でそれは潰しちゃうんです
知りたくて いくら仏教をいじめても
とにかくこの人は知りたがってるんだと
ですから 教えるのはこちらの義務だよということで教えてあげます
だからといって だからそこはちょっと注意ですけど
我々はいつでも親切な言葉を語ってくれるという
そういうことはちょっと約束できません
時々もう心に刺さるようなことも言ってしまう
それでもやっぱり私たちは責任を持ってしゃべってますよ
たとえ社会批判しても
個人に対してすごい傷つくことを言っても
それには責任持ちます
なぜそう言ったんでしょうかと
ですから 人を叱って逃げることはしません
違ったら それはちゃんと処理もします
そういうブッダの教えなんですね
ですから そこら辺をよく理解していただきたいんです
世界で初めて現れた世界宗教であって
なぜ世界宗教かというと
どんな人間にもこれは実践して心の安らぎを味わうことはできるんです
それで仏教を語ることになったら
なんで人間苦しむのか なんで人間がそんなに心が重いんですかと
なんで悩むんですかと
そこら辺は全部手術して摘出しなくちゃいけないんですよ
摘出するというんですか
取り出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
それがちょっと痛いかもしれません
みんなちょっと戸惑うのはそこら辺だと思います
そういうふうに語っている教えなんです
それである王様がお釈迦様のところに行ってこう言うんですよ
あんた方にはね ろくに住むところもない
いろんなところでお寺とかありましたけど
どこでもあったわけじゃないんだから
旅をしているんだからね
木の下でも公園ででも
どこでも横になって寝るとかね
ちゃんと毎日ご飯いただくということでもない
たくさん持ち物もない
もう三衣しか持ってない
お金もない 何もない 家族もない
でも ブッダとブッダの弟子たちの顔を見ると
ものすごく明るく輝いているんだと
いつでも何となくかすかな微笑みがあるんだと
私は他の宗教の人々もでも王様だからね
付き合ったり 話したり
説法を聞いたりしますよと
でも みんなものすごいきつい顔をして
すごい苦しい顔をしているんだと
ものすごい真剣 真面目な顔をしているんだと
すごく硬いんだと なんか強引で嫌で
誰かに脅迫されて修行しているような感じだよと
なんでブッダの弟子たちがそんなに明るくて
そんなにも気楽で輝いてますかと
お釈迦様の答えは私たち
私にも私の弟子たちにも
心の中で 今のテーマにまとめて言えば
何のストレスもないと
期待することもないし
希望することをしてしがみついて頑張るということもそんなことでもないし
心配することも何もないし
心は安らぎを味わっているんだ
だからみんな結構明るいんだよと
仏弟子たちがすごく明るいということは
もうかなり仏教のことを噂になるときはよく噂になったことなんですね
時々批判的な噂っていうのは
あの人々はかなり楽をしているんだと
それにお釈迦様は反対しません
そうですよ 我々 我こそ楽をしているんだと
我こそ人生楽しんでるんだよと
堂々とそれを肯定するんです
ちょっとこれはよくない
宗教家だからね そんな楽をしてはいけませんとか
もうちょっと真剣にみんなに批判されないように修行らしくしなくちゃいけないと
そんな見栄はないんです
世界に褒めてもらうために苦行に励むとかね
断食に励むとか みんなに拝んでもらいたく
もうなんとか行をするとかね
それはない それで批判されちゃったら
あんた方はね よくご飯も食べて
一食でしたけど それもご飯食べて
毎日何の苦行もしないで贅沢楽をしているのではないか
お釈迦様は何のこと？我こそ 楽ですよと
ある日 ちょっと論争になりまして
あんたそんなに楽というならば
コーサラ王様の方がもっと楽だよと
だってものすごい大きな国を治めて
ものすごい財産の持ち主で
美人いっぱい自分の宮殿にいて
あれほど贅沢するその人が楽ですよと言ったら
お釈迦様はすぐ違ったんです
いい加減なことを言うなよと
物事を言うならば ちゃんと論理的に証拠を出して語るべきですよと
誰が楽ですかと それでお釈迦様がこう聞くんです
この王様にたった一瞬でも
たった瞬間でもね
今風に言えば １秒２秒でもね
何もややこしいことを考えないで
何も悩むことを考えないで
心にかすかにも邪魔する苦しみを作る
もう雑念が全部消されて
穏やかな気持ちでいることできますかと
何も思考しないで それから徹底した絶対的な安らぎを感じながら
1分で見られますか？と言ったら
これは無理と 政治やらなくちゃいけない
いろんな管理しなくちゃいけない
いろんな判断しなくちゃいけない
寝たってもろくに寝られない
それでお釈迦様はこう言うんです
私は 1 分だけじゃなくて
1時間でも 2 時間でも
1日でも2日でも3日でも
時々 1週間もそういるんだよと
ずっと 心に何の思考も成り立たない
何の概念も生まれない
で すごい安らぎを感じる
体でも心でも いわゆる微かな不純物も入らない純粋に安らぎを感じて
それは 1週間でもいられますよと
だから贅沢してるのは誰ですかと
という経典がございます
そういうことですから
仏教っていうのは 心の悩み苦しみをなくすための大変幸福な教えなんですよ
そこでどんな人でも明るくいたいという希望があるんです
楽しく生活したいと それは誰にでもある希望
誰でも顔がね ちょっと硬くなってきつくなってはいたくないんですよ
どんな人でも どんな年ででも輝いて生きていきたいという気持ちがあるんです
でも残念ながらできないんです
残念ながらそれはできないんです
だから 人間のすべての人間の希望ですよ
それが たとえ文化を作らないで
ブッシュマンという方々みたいに森の中で生活していても
苦しみたくはないんですよ
気持ちよく 明るく 楽しく生きていきたいんです
それは動物を見ても同じことなんです
必死になって苦しみたい
苦しみたいと思う動物はいません
安らぎを探し求めているんですよ
でも 残念なことにそれができないんですよ
だから 唯一 希望叶わない生き方っていうのは無知な生き方です
単純です 生まれた瞬間からもういろんな希望 人間にありますよ
数えられないほど希望はあるんだけど
世の中でずっとすべての生命に共通している希望が
安らぎ 楽しく楽に生きていきたいという希望なんです
それが実現できない我々の生き方っていうのは
智慧の生き方やと言えないんですよ
だからブッダの教えも愚か者というところから始めてしまうんですよ
それに怒ったなら なんでそんなことを言うんですかと
我々はどこら辺頭が悪いんですかと反論すればよろしいのです
そうすると 一つ一つ証拠を出しながら教えてあげる
それを直せばいいのです
そういうことだから 仏教っていうのは
人間が愚か者という状態から賢者になる道なんです
智慧の人間になる道なんです
そういうことで 他の宗教とちょっと区別して考えていただきたいんですよ
死後 なんとか約束とか
そういうこの遠い未来の約束のために今苦しんでいる生き方ではないんです
それは毎日毎日 ほんのわずかでも智慧を開発して開発して
ああ 自分なりによくできましたと
これぐらい智慧があるんだよと
それで人生は楽になりましたよと
そういう方向で究極的な智慧が開発するまで
一歩一歩前へ進めばよろしいんです
そこら辺にまた最後に戻りますので
今日のポイントの真ん中の方に入ります
なんで私たちは 気楽に生きていられないでしょうか ということ
私たちにはやらなくてはならないことがいっぱいあるんですよ
ものすごいあるんです
あれもやらなくては これもやらなくてはとか
義務が多い 義理もものすごい多い
それで守らなくてはいけないもの
あるというともうきりがなくあるんですよ
それから最後にあるのはいろんな希望
もう義務が多いのに
義理も多いのに 守らなくてはいけないことが多いのに
その上希望もあるんですね
それから願望もあります
希望と願望とは少々心理的には違います
同じものじゃないんです
希望もあって願望もあります
その上 それでも大変なのに欲望もあります
欲望は病気なんです 今まで言ったことはもうどうしようもないかもしれません
欲望は病気です 希望と願望と違って
なぜ病気というんですかというと
例えば 希望が努力すれば叶う可能性はありますよ
欲望はそう叶わないんですよ
ぐるぐると変わりますから
ころころ変わるんです
増えるんです 叶ったなと思ったら
欲望自体が増えてしまって
もう叶ってないんですよ
それが精神的な病気になって
もう大変な苦しみになるんです
ですから 欲望は気をつけた方がいいんです
希望・願望は 努力すればもうそれは なんとかなるかもしれません
そういうことで我々は大変なんですよ
例えば 義務が多いということはどういうことかと
朝起きたらこれやらなくちゃいけない
料理を作らなくちゃいけないとかね
いろいろ日常生活の中でやらなくてはいけない義務がいっぱいあるんです
よく見てください その義務を果たすために寝るまで時間がかかるんですよ
寝る時も時々いろんなことをやってないんですよ
今日掃除する予定でしたけど
できなかったとかね 今日洗濯もできなかったとかね
明日の買い物しておけばよかったのに
明日のためにこれもできなかったとかね
そうやって しょっちゅうなんですよ
寝る時来て考えてみたら
自分の毎日の義務も完全に果たしてないんです
いわゆる一日かかるんですよ
義務を果たすために それから義理の場合はどうですかね
義理っていうのは 否応なしにやらなくちゃあかんことでしょう
誰かさんの葬式に行かなくちゃいけないとかね
結婚お祝いを贈らなくてはいけないとか
親戚挨拶に行かなくちゃいけないとかね
引っ越しの報告を出さなくちゃいけないとか
新しい家を建てたら それは何といいますか
なんとかお祝いというんですね
そういうお祝いをしなくちゃいけないとかね
そういうふうに いっぱい義理もあります
それ忘れちゃうんです
忙しくて 命日は忘れる
墓参りは忘れる それ忘れちゃうと大変なことになりますね
別にお化けが出てきて首を絞めるわけじゃないんだけど
親戚の間で いろんなことを言われる
会社の社長にお中元を忘れちゃったら
社長がそれで貧乏になってホームレスになるわけじゃないんだけどね
どうせ中元にもらうものも全部いらんもんばっかしでしょうしね
もらって迷惑なんですけど
それ忘れたらまた大変なことになるでしょうに
年賀状をみんなに作って
郵便局に持っていくところで
1枚でも落ちちゃったら
自分が書いたつもりですけど
行ってない これまた大変なことになります
だからこの義務を果たすのももう大変であって
その上義理も果たさなくちゃあかんでしょう
どうでしょうかね ストレスたまらないで済むんですかね
それで人生は そこで守る世界
いっぱいあります まず出てくるのは家族を守るとかね
それまた大変 自分の収入の資源をね
ちゃんと守っていかなくちゃいけない
それまたすごい大変 会社が倒産しないように
自分の首が飛ばないように
リストラにならないように
これ簡単ですかね 子供が大きくなると不良にならないように
学校でいじめられないように
守らなくちゃいかんでしょ
守られますかね じゃあ両親に何ができますかね？子供が学校でいじめられている
いじめられないようにすること何かありますか？何一つもないと思いますけど
そういうことでも できなくてできなくて
かなりストレスがたまるんですよ
かなり苦しむんですよ
かなり悩むんですよ それでどうでもいい馬鹿げたことを守っちゃうんですよ
それ守ろうとしてまた苦しむんです
どうでもいい馬鹿げたことっていうのは
人間の思考的な生き方ですね
例えば我々は日本人だとかね
日本人を守らなくてはあかんと
人類なんですけど それで人類は民族に分かれているんですね
それで我が民族ということになって
それを守らなくちゃいけない
母国というくだらん考え方を作って
それまた守らなくてはいけない
そのために戦う みんなに迷惑をかける
かけたらかけられますね 逆にまた
それで宗教争いやるんですよね
我が宗教を守らなくちゃあかんと
どうでもいいことですけど
宗教捨てちゃえば簡単なのに
それはしないで 徹底的に守るために戦って
苦しみを味わって死んでしまう
またあります 自分のプライドを守るとか
立場を守るとか そういうどうでもいいこと
何の役にも立たないことを守ろうとする
文化を守ろうとか 守りきれないんですよ
バーミヤンの仏像は守ったんですかね
世界でね 日本の方も大変それに国連で頑張りましたよ
なんとか守ってあげようと
その関連の会長は日本の方ですからね
ユネスコの 普通我々みたいに黙って待っていたわけじゃないです
もうちゃんと すごい
それには-攻撃ではなくて
ちゃんと反論して しゃべるべきところにちゃんとしゃべって
国連も動かして ものすごく頑張ったんですけど
守られますかね 守られたんでしょうかね
跡形もなく消されちゃったんです
だから結局 人類の遺産で文化遺産でね
守ろうとしたんだけど
結局もう守られなくなる
それが本当に我々に対して大変感情的なものでもあったならば
これだけでも戦争になるぐらいのものなんですよ
イスラエルとパレスチナの戦争っていうのは
そういう守りでしょうに
これは我々のお祈りの聖地だと思って
一つの宗教を守ろうとする
または他の宗教 我々の聖地だよと思って守ろうとする
でも お互いに世界でね
キリスト教生まれた場所でしょうし
イスラム教 ユダヤ教の約束の場所やいろんなことを言うところなんですけど
そこでどれぐらい人が死ぬかというと
なんで平和を語った人が誕生したところで
みんな平和を謳わないんですかね
仲良く人類みんなそちらに行って
仏教の人々もそちらに行ってお参りに
ここで西洋の方で人類に平和を語った人が生まれたんだよと
そこで殺されたんだよと
感動すればいいのに どうですかね
今の状態って そういうふうに人間の この苦しみというのは
守る意味があろうかなかろうか
何かを守ろうとする 時々
この家 歴史のほんのわずか古い
もうせいぜい100年ぐらいでもいいんですよ
古い家にお嫁に行ったら
それでその家の人々は
こちらの伝統を守らなくちゃあかんって
あのお嫁さんいじめる
それで精神的にものすごい苦しみを味わったりする
時々 三代目まで続けた会社だからといって
全く商売にならない ご飯を食べることはできない
収入で それでも苦労して苦労して守ろうとする
だから それで何が得られるかというと
生きること自体が苦しみになる
具体的に苦しみになる
そうやってこの守るということも
一見美しく聞こえることなんですけど
いくら美しく聞こえても
人間の苦しみを作る原因になっていることは断固たる事実なんです
民族争いってものすごい一番いい例なんですよ
民族の歴史自体もおかしいんですよ
初めから民族を作って
我々はもう 2000年の古い民族だとかね
それで他の民族を殺したりいじめたりする
あるいは同じ民族であろうとも
なんか変な宗教をとってやったら
それで 激しく喧嘩したりする
このボスニアとかね そこら辺の問題っていうのは
民族と同時に宗教争いなんですね
それで ロシアにも一つありますね
どこでしたっけ？地方は
チェチニア？チェチェン？
大変でしょうに 殺すは殺されるわということで
それ宗教ですよ チェチェニアはイスラム教だから
もうソ連とは仲良くしたくないと
別に独立したいと だから幸福を作ってくれてるんですかね
そうすると なんで仲良くしないんですかね
人類として 作っているのは苦しみだけでしょうに
そういうことで 皆様に私は理解してほしいのは
この何かを守るということも
結局は人間に苦しみ 悩み
ストレス すべてを作ってくれるんだということなんです
だから そういう話をすると大体は怒られますけどね
じゃあ文化壊せと言うんでしょうかとかね
そういうことを私は言っていないのは
私は中道を語っているんだからね
私はではなくて 仏教は
ですから もう何か壊せということではないんですけど
非論理的でくだらないことに戦うなよと
苦しむなよと この間 木曜日
質問されたんですよ どなたから
今日いらっしゃるかどうか分かりませんだけどね
バーミヤン仏像とかね
ああいうニュースを聞くと
すごく腹が立ってくるんだと
なんでそういうことを壊しますかと
私はどう思いますか？と
私は別に何も思ってないんだと
それほど壊したければいいんじゃないんですかと
それほど私も反対ってやることはもう当然のこと反対ですけど
だからといって それほどアフガニスタンの方々にあの仏像あることは迷惑だったら
アフガニスタンの方々の貧しさ
苦しみがあの仏像のせいだったらね
壊した方がいいんでしょうと
それでアフガニスタンは世界で大変豊かな国になるでしょ
あれが宗教的に問題でしたから
アンイスラミックという偶像崇拝は
今イスラミックでしょ
純粋にイスラム主義的だからね
見てください
2.3年でね 世界で肩並べる豊かな国になりますからね
ですから 彼らの思考はそういう思考だから
しょうがないでしょうに
放っておけば ですから
私は全然そんなことには怒りも何も感じないんです
ただ悲しいだけ なんてアホな人間かと
そんなことあってもね
別にかゆくも痛くもないのに
何か仏像やらそれあっただけでイスラム教が壊れるんだったらね
ろくな宗教ではないでしょうと
だからそこら辺の自分たちの屁理屈に気がつかない
その人間の無知 それは悲しい
何もわからない 何も理解できない
何の判断能力もないぐらい
人間としては情けないところは悲しいだけなんですね
逆に楽しいんですよ だってそこまでそんなことまで考えるんでしょうかと
放っておけばいいのにね
だから私も破壊したことを放っておきます
別に気にしないと また考えればどんなものでも壊れるでしょうに
ピラミッドも壊れるわ
古代文明も壊れちゃったし
もうみんな作るというか
バカでかいものを作るんだけどね
Roman Empire.. ローマ帝国見たっても
がらくただけでしょうに
そういうことだから
どんなものを自然の法則の中でも壊れてはいく
誰か壊さなくたっても
そういうことだから
落ち着いていられます
腹が立たずにいられます
そういうことで 一応我々のストレスたまる原因
苦しみたまる原因っていうのはそういう原因であります
それで次に この機能
どういう機能かというと
私たちには例えば義務が多いでしょうに
義務が多い 義理も多い
それでよく見てください
時間足らないんですよ
1日の仕事を終了するためにも
1日の時間は足らない
その上 仕事もしなくちゃいけない
社会的な義理義務も果たさなくちゃいけない
自分の体の面倒を見なくちゃいけない
時間がないんですよ 学校から電話かけてきたら
あなたの子供はちょっとトラブルを起こしましたから
早く学校に来いと 家で何やっていたっても
料理作っていたっても
天ぷら作ろうと思って全部用意して油ももう温めていた途中かもしれません
それはそのままやめて学校に行かなくちゃいけないんです
すると帰ってきたら食べるものはないと
ということにもなるし
そういうふうに我々にはすごい時間がないんですよ
それどうしますかというと
何一つもろくにしない
どんな仕事も中途半端で
途中でもうやめる それで心にある問題が起きちゃうんですよ
ジャガイモを皮をむきながら
心がジャガイモに行かないんです
子供のことをどうしようかとか
買い物のことをどうしようかとか
洗濯物は大丈夫かな？とかね
心はそうやって英語でfluctuateと言うんですけど
飛び回っちゃうんです
いつでも あっちこっちあっちこっち心が飛び回る
子供も同じことで 学校で勉強する時でも
心がいろんなところに飛び回っている
一箇所にとどまらないんです
仕事をしている時も 将来のことやら過去のことやら
家のことやら いろんなことに心が飛び回る
飛び回っちゃうと仕事は中途半端になる
失敗はする それで3分の仕事は10分以上かかる
1時間で読める本は あっちこっち飛び回る心で読むと3時間もかかる
時間なくなって明日にまで回されたりもします
考えてみてください
今すでに時間がないのに
心が飛び回ることによって
さらに時間取ってしまう
掃除をするために15分だと決めても
もう15分も もう時間ないぐらいなんですね
15分かかったら他の仕事に時間がないんですよ
それなのにあっちこち心が飛び回しながら掃除機をかけると
15分のところを30分
40分かかってしまうんです
さらにひどい状態になるんですよ
これは国の赤字国債と同じなんです
増える一方で 減る見込みはないんだと
どうでしょうかね そうすると我々の生き方っていうのは
1日の義務だけ果たすことでも24時間取れるのに
その上 義理やら他の仕事やらもう守ることやら
もうそれもかかってしまって
もう1日はもう1週間ぐらい延ばしてくれないと
時間足らない状態で それで仕事をすると
それまた3倍時間取ってしまったりする
わざと時間を取る 時間を取る
全て無知な原因なんですよ
この時間延ばすと 私は時々客観的に観察するんですよ
なんて無知かアホかって時々言いたくなるぐらい
単純ではないかと こういう風にすぐ終われるものではないかと
それで時間取ってしまう
心がこの自分 今やる仕事に定着しないことで大変な問題が起きます
どういうことかというと
喜びが消える こういうことなんですよ
私たちは頑張って何か仕事をしたところで
やったぞという充実感が生まれるでしょ
やったぞと それが全然ないんですよ
だって掃除機かけても他のことを考えながら
もう慌てて慌てて早くやっているでしょうに
この早く掃除機かけてるんだから
15分の掃除機には大体30分かかってしまっちゃうんですね
随分早いんですけど
30分で料理などできますけど
大体3時間かかります
なぜかというと 早くやっているからなんです
それだけじゃないんですよ
あの充実感もないんです
「やったぞ」ということ
やっと終わったというね
ああ 嫌だとかね それで終わっちゃうんですよ
ああ 嫌だ 大変だと だから掃除機終わっちゃうと
どれぐらいストレス 怒り溜まってるかというと
できれば掃除機も畳んで置くんじゃなくて
そのまま捨ててしまいたいぐらい
足で蹴っ飛ばして出て行けと言いたいぐらい
もう ストレスは溜まってるんですよ
料理そこでどれぐらいストレス溜まっちゃうというと
この食器がいっぱいもう洗わなくちゃいけないので
できればそのまま それはもうもう潰して捨てたいぐらいの気持ちなんです
仕事はどれぐらい楽しいかというと
もうクビにならないんだったら
社長をぶん殴っちゃうんです
それぐらいの気持ちです
だから我々の生き方はそういう生き方なんです
だから 誰一人もあの楽しみを味わってない
やったぞという楽しみが できたぞと
終わったよと どんな仕事でも
たとえ単純なことでも
きちんと早く上手に失敗なく
やってしまえばなんとなく楽しいんですよ
よくできましたと その楽しみというのは
その充実感なんですよ
その楽しみがあると ストレスはたまりません
ですから 仏教から見れば
普通の人間の生き方っていうのは
苦しみ ストレス 苦しみ
ストレス 悩み そういうものだけ溜まる
生き方 少々その生き方を変えれば
瞬間瞬間楽しみを味わう
充実感を味わう生き方にはなります
心に対しては 仏教では人間の心っていうのは
猿頭だというんですよ
猿頭といえば
日本語訳は失礼になっちゃうんですね
英語ではmonkey mindなんですよ
我々の心っていうのは
猿のようで落ち着かなくて
あっちこっちあっちこっち 飛び回っているんだと
一箇所に止まれよと 一つの仕事をもう真面目にやりなさいよと
終わるまで それができないんです
だから完全に人生そのものが失敗 一つですよ
その理由は この心が飛び回っていることなんです
そこで人間の幸せっていうのは
ご飯にあるものじゃないんですよ
座る椅子にあるものじゃないんですよ
幸せっていうのは心の喜びなんです
ご飯食べておいしかったと
その気持ちが幸せであって
ご飯が幸せではありません
お金も幸せではありません
この心の喜びなんですよ
そこで心が喜ぶためには「やりました」と
その自慢が必要なんです
それが自慢かもしれませんだけど
やったよと 終わったよと
その心に 認識に その終了宣言必要なんです
この終了宣言しない限り
心が不安定な状態なんです
それはもう微妙なところなんですけど
テーマは簡単だから
ちょっと論理的なところばっかり今日喋ってます
微妙なところなんですけど
やっぱりこの仕事をなんか途中で
例えば何でもいいんですよ
途中でやめてみてください
大事な仕事を後にしますと
その時から心になんとなく不安定状態
イライラ状態残るでしょうに
終わらなかった仕事がいくつかあるんだと
この締め切りとかあったりする場合は
まだ自分で仕事をやってない
手を出してない あるいは終わってない
後回しにしている その時
気持ちはどうですかね
確定申告は明日ですですけど
今日もまだ書いてないと
心の状態はどうですかね
かなり激しいんですよ
かなり苦しいんですよ
どんな仕事でも 鼻の先に来たら
今はいいや 明日にするそうとちょっと延期してみてください
心はどうなるかと それで心がすごい不安定な状態になるんです
イライラするんです 楽しみは消されちゃうんですよ
例えば仕事あるんだけど
やっぱりこれはやめてテレビ見ますよと
テレビ見ても テレビも楽しめないんですね
ずっと心が あれ やっぱり
やっぱりやらなくちゃ でもテレビ見る
やっぱりやらなくちゃいかん
でもテレビ見るという状態になるんですね
これ終わってからやるんだとか
そうするとテレビを見る楽しみも消されちゃうし
仕事をしなかったことの苦しみもどんどん増えていくし
それで仕事を始めようと思ったら
もう時間ない 時間テレビに取られちゃったんだから
なんで時間ないんでしょうか？とか
また自分を責めたりもするし
その生き方 ですから この幸福っていうのは終了宣言
どんなつまらない どんな小さな仕事でも
終了した瞬間で心がすっごく安らぎ感じるんです
それが誰にでもないんですよ
ですから 私たちは24時間生きてるし
その24時間の中でいろんなことをやってますよ
だから たとえどんなつまらないことでも
やること やること やること
その場でその場で終了すると
そうするとどうですかね
その場でその場で終了する
そうすると その瞬間 その瞬間
安らぎを感じない？ 喜びを感じない？
心に終了宣言をちゃんとインプットしないと
心が安らぎを感じないんです
ブッダの悟りの道もそういう道なんですよ
悟りも開いたら終了宣言するんですよ
自動的に全ての仕事の終了宣言
どれほど安らぎあると思いますか？だから仏典みてください
なすべきことは成し終えたと
修行するべきところは全部修行し終えましたと
これからやることないんだよと
これが人にできる最高な究極的な終了宣言なんです
それがすべての幸福よりも絶対的な幸福であると
だからNibbānaṃ paramaṃ sukhaṃ
涅槃こそが paramaṃ 最高たる 最勝で 一番優れている sukhaṃ
Happiness 幸福であると
すごい論理的にブッダの教えわかると思います
日常生活の中ででも 我々何かできたら
何か仕事を終わるまで
終わるまでして終了したと
終わったと やったと思った瞬間で喜び感じる
それの延長線ですよ 解脱は
決して変なわからない神秘的なものではありません
そういうことで ストレスはそういうふうに出てきますね
仕事はガタガタにする
途中でやめたりする 後回しにする
それで心がイライラする
不安定な状態になる それですごい
それがストレスなんです
それから人間にはもう仕事多いんだから
1日が1週間に伸ばしてくれても
地球はゆっくり回してゆっくり回しちゃうと燃えちゃいますけどね
それでもいいんだから
ゆっくり回して 1日には1週間の時間をつけてくれても
我々にはまだやり残している仕事はいっぱいあるんですよ
ですから 人間のこの生き方では
ストレスないように生きるといえば
これはもう皆無 無理やというぐらい無理なんですね
それぐらい我々のは あれもやらなくちゃ
これもやらなくちゃ あれもやりたい
これもやりたい その上
願望もあって 希望もあって
毎日忙しいのに もしその上欲望まで出てきたら
この世で欲望なんかない人間いるんでしょうかね
だから本当は我々はどこまで苦しみにストレスを感じているかというと
もう怖くなるほど感じています
お釈迦様のたとえで言うならば
膨大な大きな穴に炭火を入れて
それ真っ赤に燃えているところで
人の体を矢で刺して その炭火の穴の中に入れてぐるぐる回しているような状態だよと
どこに回しても燃えちゃうんですよ
痛いんですよ だから槍で刺されただけでも大変でしょうに
それであの豚の丸焼きのような感じで
その炭火で真っ赤に燃えている
大きな穴の中に自分を入れて回されちゃうと
かなりきついでしょうね
それがお釈迦様がおっしゃっているこのストレスの量なんです
誰でもそれぐらい感じているんです
だから涼しいところは生まれた瞬間からも感じていないんです
だから我々はあまり気にしない
溶岩の中に生まれたような感じで
燃えてはいるんだけど
比較することはないんです
そういうことだから みんなこの
炭火の中にいるんだけど
ちょっと紙でも一つ背中に貼ってもらっちゃえば
すごい気持ちいいやとかね
そんな感じでこの一時的な措置をしていますよ
じゃあ 炭火の中にいる人の背中に紙を一つ
新聞紙一つ貼ってあげると
それで暖かいという 熱いということは消えますかね
瞬間消えますよ でも完璧じゃないんです
瞬間消えるんだけど 次の瞬間
あの新聞紙が燃えちゃうんですよ
燃えちゃうんだからさらに痛いんです
だから我々やっていることはそういうことなんです
いろいろもう何か工夫します
このストレスなくそうと思って
かえってもっと大きなストレスが生まれてくる
その生き方をしています
では 一旦休憩いたします
次のところに入ります
どうもありがとうございます
それではまた始まります
私たちの人生っていうのは
そういう風にこの中途半端で生きているんだから
いろいろ失敗起きますから
それから後悔になったりもするし
失敗 また失敗しましたかということで
それから自信もなくなっちゃうんですね
だから本当にこの自信あって生きる人っていうのは
なかなか世の中にないんですよ
いつでも不安というかね
自信がないんですね それもこの一つの
我々の生き方の問題ですよ
瞬間瞬間の仕事を終了宣言までするならば
これが失敗しなかったと
これがよくできたという自信が出てくるんですね
それも人間にはないんですよ
そういう生き方で 次の
ストレスの世界  これからもうちょっと難しくなるかもしれませんだけど
人間っていうのは 仏教は智慧の世界だから
物事を知っておかないとどうにもならないんですね
世界はちゃんと正しく知っておく必要があります
知ったかぶりは大変危険なんですね
知るということは必要なんですよ
一般的に我々は知識人だ
現代世界はすごい知識の世界だとかね
昔と今は随分違うんだとか
今は情報の社会だと もう何でも知ることはできるんだぞというふうな
我々現代人にはかなりこの
何て言いますかね ちょっと舞い上がっているところもあります
ちょっとのところじゃないんですけど
古い人々は馬鹿にしちゃうんですよ
何も知らない 知らないでしょうとかね
そこで仏教からの疑問
あんた方は本当に世の中を知ってますかと
知ったかぶりだけではないかと
という疑問を投げかけているんです
どういうことかというと
我々は何か見ると 何か聞くと
何か味わうと 何か考えると
ありのままに 見よう・聞こう としないんです
選ぶんです 好きなもの
好きなものを見ると 好きなものを聞くと
好きなものを味わうと
好きなことをすると 好きなことを勉強すると
というと それは良く知ることですかね？
この人が自分の主観で判断しているだけでしょう
知ってないんです だから情報っていうのはすごく自然に体に触れるんですよ
情報が別に何のこともなく
何のコントロールもなく
ただ体に触れる でもこちらで何か尺度を作って情報を処理しちゃうんですね
だから私が知っているのは入った情報ではなくて
自分の好みなんです
その大変な大きな問題なんです
ですから この固定概念いっぱいありまして
ご飯は美味しいとかね
花は綺麗ですとか ゴッホの絵はすごい綺麗ですよとかね
誰かさんの音楽は一番いいんですよとかね
そういう風にいろいろまず固定概念いっぱい作って
それを追っていく そうすると自分好んだ楽しみが出てこない
例えばこのご飯がおいしいんだと思って食べてみたら楽しくないと思ったら
これにはこれを合わせてあれも合わせてこれも合わせて食べましょうと
その方がおいしいですよと
強引にその情報を変えるんですよ
あの独裁国の厳密な共産主義の国々の新聞情報と同じなんです
事実ではなくて 自分でニュースを作って言いたいことを言うと
それで私たちもなんとかご飯おいしいですよと言って
もうそれ食べてみて ちょっと食べてみて
それからこれに塩をかけましょう
ごまを振りましょう
何かまた入れましょうとかね
そういうふうにしてわざと変化させて食べる
それで見るものをわざと変えて見る
だから自然破壊もいいところでしょうね
自分の好みで何でもかんでも 破壊していく
結局は知ってないんですよ
それから好きなものが出てくると
必ずしもそれ以外のものは嫌いなものになるんですね
それで嫌いなものと判断して
その固定概念で世の中を見ると
全部もう反対する 拒絶する
攻撃する 壊しに行く だから世の中を見ていないんです
こちらで嫌いと判断して
その人はどうであろうとも壊しちゃう
そうやって世の中で 例えば宗教は大嫌いだとか平気で言うでしょうね
私の話を聞いたこともない人々はかなり批判するんですね
私は話を聞いてみろと
そんな批判があったら面と向かって言いなさいよと
なんで腰抜けで逃げて隠れて言うんでしょうかと
と言いたいところですけど
知らないんだからね どちらでも関係ないんですけど
とにかく自分で嫌いと決めたら全部嫌いと
坊主が憎けりゃ袈裟まで憎いということことわざの通りなんですよ
それで何でも壊しに行く
それで世界知るということにならないんですよ
それでどうなるかというと
我々はものすごく硬くなる
頑固になる 自然を壊す
自然な生き方 それまた壊しちゃう
自然の中で流れて生きるべきなのに
我々は自分の人生っていうのを全て今もうとっくに壊しているんですよ
体のためだと思って 毒しか食べるものはなくなっているし
空気は汚れているし 綺麗にしようと思って建物を造るために使う材料なんかは
いろんな化学物質を出したりして
それまた体にも悪いし
なんでそうなるんでしょうかというと
自分で好きな方にするんだから
なんでも 好きな方に変えようとする
嫌なことは変えようとする
それで世の中知られなくなります
それは仏教でいう大変有名な人間の心の中の感情ですね
貪りと怒り これがすごいストレスになるんです
欲を作ってみてください
すごいストレスなんです
人に恋でもしてみてください
うそインチキな歌なんかはなんと美しいやと
とんでもないんですよ
かなり精神的にストレスかかるんです
ものすごい精神的にストレスかかるんですよ
欲が生まれたら 怒りを作ってみてください
落ちつけますかと あれが嫌
これが嫌とかね ずいぶんわがままで自己本位で嫌なものをいっぱい作ってみてください
もう生きていられなくなります
ものすごいストレス溜まっちゃうんです
それで知ることもできなくなる
それから我々はもっとすごいことをするんですよ
無視するということをするんです
情報が触れるんだけど
無視する 好きでもないんだから
嫌いでもないんだから
流しちゃう 無視する
この無視することは仏教では無知と言うんです
私たちはこの世界を知るではなくて
貪瞋痴で世界を変えようとしているんです
好きなものは追っていく
嫌なものは壊しに行く
他のものは無視して馬鹿になる
知らないんだ そんなことは
気にしなかったと 平気で無視する
その 3つで 心の中で貪瞋痴という硬い性格が出来上がっちゃうんです
それですごい頑固で もう硬くてもう曲げない人間になるんです
いろいろ私はあれだこれだとか
大変好き嫌い激しいやと言ったら
その人とは付き合うことさえも難しいでしょうに
折れないんだから 柔軟性がない
もう硬い その人がそれから自分と戦わなくちゃいけない
世界と戦わなくちゃいけない
戦えますかね それですっごくストレス溜まる
だからストレス溜まるもの
根本的な原因は この貪瞋痴という貪りと怒りと無知というこの 3つなんです
何を失うかというと 智慧を失うんです
ありのままの世界を失うんです
ですから 人類が言っていることはまとめて言えば嘘です
簡単に言えます 例えば
科学発展こそ人間には素晴らしいというと
全然幸福になってないでしょうに
全然我々に余裕も安らぎもないでしょうに
発展はしていますよ 確実に
いっぱい道具は作ってはありますよ
じゃあ暇がありますか？人生それで楽しいんですか？
新しいものを作れば作るほど
ものすごい馬鹿高くて 手に入らないんですよ
そうすると 今までの仕事量はさらに倍にして仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
約束だけのリーニアモーターカーというものがね
もし商売始めたら やっぱり望むよりも 3倍払わなくちゃいけないんですよ
大阪に行くために そうすると私たちはもっと仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうするともっと時間なくなっちゃうだけなんです
結局嘘ですよ 言っているのは科学的なもの
発展すればするほど 人間がそれで幸せになるんだと言って逆なんですよ
それで大変で生きていられなくなるだけなんです
なんでそうなるかというと
全て貪瞋痴で考えるからなんです
この間  NHK で見たんだけど
この手術ロボットを開発しているんです
あれ見たら素晴らしい技術だと
体を切りません  ３箇所で穴開けて
穴から細い管を入れて
一つはカメラ 一つは光とカメラ
もう一つで 2つでちゃんと手術をする
切るところは切って取るところは取り出しちゃって
ロボットが体の中で縫うところも縫ってくれる
そこであの細い管を出せば
小さな穴3つだから それ閉めればいいんです
だから患者さんには確かに負担はない
その私は本当にあれはすごいと思いますよ
でも問題はあの機械の値段なんですよ
普通の人には手術を受けられません
かなりお金がないと
普通 10万円で払って済むものだったら
あの機械を使って手術したらやっぱり 40 万･50 万になるんです
幸せなことには保険きかない
ですから 考えてみてください
とにかく新しい技術だから
広げるだろうと思いますし
人間にとってはいいことだから広げるだろうと広げてほしいしね
私でも でも私の考え方を見れば
もうどんな病院でもそういう機械があって
誰にでも簡単にその恩恵を受けられるように
した方がいいでしょうに
それだったら このロボットを開発した人々はすごい苦労して開発していたんだから
その人々には各国の政府やら
もういろんな資金を出して
じゃあどうぞお金あげるんだから
これからお金を取るなよと
あっちこっちでみんなでそれ作りましょうと
これ人類のためになるんだよと
買えない人々にも買えるようにしてあげましょうと
そうやって人類にちょっとだけでも安らぎを作ってあげようというところ
するべきところなんですけど
逆に特許を取られて ものすごいお金を払わなきゃ買えないし
病院も商売やらなくちゃいけないんだから
もう高いお金 料金取らないとできなくなるし
やっぱり一見いい技術なんですけど
またそのために我々はさらに働かなくちゃいけない
さらに時間なくさなくてはいけないと
それから人類の一部だけその恩恵を受けて
大勢の人々はその恩恵を受けない
という世界になる だからなんでそうなるか
貪瞋痴でしょ あの人はお金ないんだから死んでもいいやと
私たちは儲かるためにそれを作っているんだと
儲かってどうするんですかね
儲かる儲かるという言葉自体おかしいんですよ
それ自体恐ろしいんですよ
それでみんな苦しんでいるんだから
気持ちよく 楽しく 仲良く
みんなで生きていればいいでしょうに
でも貪瞋痴はそうさせません
絶対儲からなくちゃいけないんだと思って
相手の財産も能力もすべて搾取する
奪う 盗む
ですから この世の中は貪瞋痴で考えているんです
それで哲学作る それで我々の生きる方法を教える
すべてもう逆さまなんです
だから見てください 世の中の人々の話を真面目にみんな聞いてるでしょうに
一向に幸せになってないでしょうに
平和平和やとみんな語っているんですけど
世界には一度も平和が訪れていない
豊かになろう 豊かになろう
貧困をもう取っ払いましょうと
言うことは言うんだけど
こんな豊かな日本でもホームレスがいる
国のために 国民のためにと政治家
政治の方々言うんだけど
真面目に話聞いて従ってみてください
とんでもないことになる
だからいろんな汚職して
賄賂したり 悪いことしたりすることはなぜバレますかというと
信じてないんだからなんですよ
だから信じてないんだから救われてます
医者のことも完璧に信じてないんだから
なんとかもう医療ミスやらいろんなことを控えて自分を守ることはできます
でなきゃ いくら手術ミスがあっても
手術は完璧だとカルテ書いちゃえばそれだけで終わっちゃいますから
手術で何か事故を起こしちゃっても
書かなかったらわからないんだから
誰も知りませんだから
平気で殺されますよ でも一般の人々もやっぱり信頼しませんと
ということだから やっぱりそういうものの問題はちゃんと明らかになって
明確になって それで医者もやっぱり気をつけろということになるんです
訴えられるんだから気をつけているんですよ
もし医者を訴えられないということになっちゃうと
もう人類は終わり その生き方なんですよ
世の中の哲学っていうのは
だから結局我々は何で救われていますかというと
人を疑うんだからなんですよ
それ事実でしょうに だから
そんな世界美しいんですかね
人を疑う生き方 人を敵だと思う生き方
人に騙されるんだとずっと神経使って気をつける生き方
楽？ でも 我々の現代2１世紀の生き方っていうのは
相手を信頼しない 騙されるかもしれませんとずっと緊張している
病院に行ってもいちいち調べてみる
病気になったらすぐそこら辺に行きましょうということではなくて
調べて調べて病院に行く
私は病院調べること自体大変おかしいと思いますよ
だって悪い病院といい病院も成り立っているんだから
頭の中で それ私が言ったら日本人を
馬鹿にしているんだと
私じゃないんですよ 皆様ですけど
平気で私に言うんだから
いい病院もありまして
悪い病院もあるんだよと
私がおかしいんじゃないんですか
悪い病院があるはずがないでしょうに
ですから 我々はそうやってこの苦しい世界
貪瞋痴のおかげさまでわざと作っているんです
人を裏切らなかったら生きていられない
人をもう裏切るじゃなくて･･･疑う
人を疑わなかったら生きていられない
この人に騙される可能性ありますよと
じっと覚えておかないと大変なことになる
それがね カラスでも群れを作って仲良く生きているのに
犬たちでももう放してあげれば
野良犬になったらきちんと群れを作って
お互いに心配し合って仲良く生きているのに
人間は 互いにみんなもう信頼しない
夫婦の間でも信頼ない
子供は親を信頼しないとか
そういう世界で生きていて
その世界素晴らしいんだと
また無知だからわかってないんですよ
なんて幸せな人生かと誤解
それは無知から言うんですね
ですから この本当に幸せな世界っていうのは
人を疑うんじゃなくて
人を信頼する 人を敵だと思うんじゃなくて
優しさ なんていい人ですかと
なんて優しい人ですかと
誰を見ても感じられる世界でしょうに
なぜそういう世界ないんでしょうかと
なぜ徹底的にストレスで固まってきているんでしょうかというと
原因はこの貪瞋痴 ですから
お釈迦様はむさぼり 怒りと無知をやめなさいと言ったら
これまたブッダにまで悪口を言うんだから
そんな生き方できっこはないんだとか
おかしいんだとか 不自然だとか
ブッダにまで言うんですよ
誰が不自然ですかね 誰がおかしいことを思っているんですかね
だって欲ばっかしに目がくらんだら自己破壊になるでしょうに
これははっきりした証拠
それしか歴史で 歴史はそれだけでしょうに
昔のバカな政治家たちが自分の国を広げようと思って
いろんな国にも戦いを挑んで
挑んでどうなったんですか？自分まで破壊してしまったでしょうに
じゃあヒットラーさんが世界制覇しました？どうなったんですかね
結局犬みたいに死んでしまっただけで
そうやって欲が 怒りが自己破壊に行くんですよ
それはいくらでも証拠はある
それでもいいと思うのは
お釈迦様はそれは無知のせいだと
観察しないせいだと 世の中ちゃんと見ておきなさい
見ておきましょうと むさぼりで
怒りで この湾曲させて
ないものを知るんじゃなくて
あるものあるがままに知っておきなさいましょうと
そうするとむさぼり 怒りも消える
そうした人にとっては
人間というのは敵じゃなくて仲間なんですよ
騙される人ではなくて
何かあったら助けてくれる人なんですよ
嫌な人ではなくて すごい優しい人なんですよ
だからブッダの教えは
こういう人類みんなもうお互いに
もう家族のように 我が子のように心配し合う
慈しみで触れ合う人々にしたかったんですけどね
あまりスケールは大きすぎですけどね
でももう世の中はそうじゃないんだから
うまく仏教っていうのは上手くいかないってことになっています
そこで心の中に貪瞋痴が出てきたら
我々はすぐ硬くなる 暗くなる
欲が出てきたらすごい顔色が暗くなるんですよ
人の話は聞けなくなる
怒りの場合は明確ですけどね
怒りで 憎しみで燃えちゃうと
ものすごい嫌な人間になるんですね
そうすると みんなその人を嫌悪して
もう離れちゃうし
他人に愛されないんですよ
そこで仏教ではこの善心所という言葉がありまして
善行為という言葉がありまして
この善行為 良い行為っていうのは
仏教の心理学では善心所が生まれた人が性格は滑らかだと
すごく楽しみを感じるんだと
柔軟性があるんだと 体も心もすごい軽いんだと
活発的になるんだと それからすごい平等で
物事を落ち着いて見ているんだと
その気持ちが徳であって
善心なんですよ 善行為なんです
それなのに善行為してくださいと言ったら
ちょっと二 三歩ぐらい下がっちゃうんですね
善行為っていうのは 人に柔軟性を与えてくれる
心も体も楽にしてくれる
笑顔を 忘れてないんですね
笑ったことないんだから
ですから笑顔というのは生まれてくる
なんとなく気持ちいいということになる
気楽になる 欲が入ったら
怒りが入ったら全く反対ですごく硬くなってしまう んです
もう嫌な存在になってしまうんです
だから このアビダンマというね
仏教の心の分析のところで
善心所 というところが説明してありまして
そちらの言っているのは善心
善い心になったら軽さ
柔軟性 それからTattramajjhattatāという言葉があります
善心所の中で どんなものについても中立的で偏らないで見ているんだと
このtatraっていうのはそこにという意味なんですけど
それはじゃあ見るもの
聞くもの いわゆる我々は見たり聞いたり喋ったりする
そのそのそのその場で
その場でmajjhattatā中立性を持つんだと
今 我々は物事はいつでも偏って見たり聞いたりしています
偏って考えたりします
それで硬くなる 善心の場合は
善行為の場合は偏らないんです
それが善心なんです その場合はストレスというのはひとかけらもないんですよ
だからストレスの人生が悪行為なんです
不善行為なんです 結論として言いますけど
ストレスというのは単なる自然の現象やとかというふうに処理できるものじゃないんです
それ自体悪行為なんです
不善なんです ストレスはない
柔らかい心でいること自体が
善行為 善なんです だからそんな簡単じゃないんですよ
カウンセラーに行って直してくれるぐらいのものやとかね
大きい声出して歌っちゃえば
カラオケでストレスは発散できるぞとかね
そんなことで治るもんじゃないんですよ
カラオケで歌っちゃうと
それでストレス溜まりますよ
かっこよく歌わなくちゃいけないんだから
それで見栄が出てきますから
それまたストレスなんですよ
じゃあ踊ってストレス発散しようと思ったら発散できません
バカになるだけ バカみたいに踊るだけで
それでかっこよく踊らなくちゃいけないんだから
猿のように踊っちゃったらみんなに笑われちゃうんだよと言って
それまた訓練するんです
踊りのやり方 それまたストレスでしょうに
そんなものでストレス解消っていうのは
発散っていうのはもうインチキもいいところですよ
ストレス自体が不善なんです
だからもう大胆なことを言いますけど
これは仏教で宗教でよく言うでしょ
悪いことをすると地獄に落ちるんだと
だからストレスの塊で死んじゃえば地獄に落ちるんだよと
冗談ですけど　そういうふうに言えます
でも冗談でもないんです
ストレスは不善なんです
不善行為なんです 早くもそれはもう取って
心がすごい柔軟性のある性格
心っていう場合は性格で覚えてください
柔軟性ある性格 いつでも 笑顔がある性格
常に楽しみを感じる性格
人の言うことについて
ああ いいですよということでもなく
もうダメですよ なんでそんなこと言うんでしょうとかね
そういう怒りも欲も出さないで
そういうことですかとちゃんと聞く性格
落ち着いている性格
だから常に落ち着いている性格がストレスのない性格なんです
そういうことで 貪瞋痴があるんだから
人間は自由がない 貪瞋痴の奴隷
欲しいものを追って生きていかなくちゃいけない
自由に生きていられない
嫌いなものを壊すために
生きて生きていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうすると 生きる道がもう決められてしまうんです
自由っていうのは失っちゃう
自由を失っちゃうと そこにあるのは苦しみ　束縛
それぐらいの話ですから
それでこの紹介する文章にあったような
この我慢とかね 言葉がありますけどね
それはもう はっきりとストレスの言葉なんですね
我慢するのは 嫌なことを我慢する
はっきりしているでしょうに
だから なんでもともと嫌なことあるんですかね
だから根本的に頭の中で何か間違ってます
我慢する場合は嫌なことは我慢するんだから
例えば病気になって体が痛いと
少々我慢しなさいよと
言葉では別に問題ないんだけど
その場合でも なんで病気は嫌だと思うんですかね
それは自然的なことだから
自然なことで 私はこういう病気になりましたと
ですから こういうところ
こういうところがものすごい痛いんですよと
なるほど これが病気の状態だと
そうやってクールで見れば
中立的に見れば 我慢ということは成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
だから物事っていうのはそんなもんだよと
もう簡単に見ておけば
我慢する必要ないんです
頑固っていうのは
もう本当にもう あまりね
それはもう頭が悪いということで
人の話は聞かないし たとえいくら間違っていたとわかっても
それは変えないというね
性格だからね それは頭の悪いという証拠ですよ
決して美しい言葉でもなんでもないんです
例えば我々男たちっていうのは
年取ればどんどん頑固になるでしょ
どんどん怠けちゃうんですね
新しいものを聞きたくないとかね
新しいものを知りたくないとか
というふうに このもう死ぬ準備ですからね
男性の体っていうのは
早くも死に準備するんだから
もう見たっても意味がないし
どうせ死ぬことだから
心ではわかっていないので
無意識ではその準備するんですね
そうするとみんなに頑固で見えちゃうんですよ
だから頑固おやじやらという言葉はあるんだけど
頑固ババアとかあまりないんですね
でも実際は女性の方はものすごい頑固なんです
平等だからどちらということはないんですけど
なんで男にそのレッテルを貼られるかというと
だいたい元気な時は頑固じゃないんですよ
もうすぐもう合わせちゃうんです
いろんなことに興味もあるし
知らないことだったらすぐそれ勉強してみる
子供でも遊びましょうと言ったら
すぐ子供の年に戻って
すぐガキの頃に戻って遊んであげたりもします
その時だから 突然
ある日突然 もう嫌ですよと
人の話聞かなくなる 孫の話聞かなくなる
その時はもう頑固というレッテルが貼られてしまいます
女性の場合は生まれつきだから
もう別に貼れるとこはないんです
ですから この頑固という性格っていうのは
もう物事を判断しないという
頭の悪いという証拠なんです
ですから 本当は仏教の世界は無常の世界を語っているんだから
毎日物事は変わる いろんなものが変わる
古いものは消える 新しいものは生まれてくる
だから常に心を開いておけば
何のこともないんです
もう何のことなく調整しながら生きていられます
いわゆる流れと一緒にいればいいんです
物事はもう瞬間たりとも止まることなく変化していくんです
それにはやっぱり知恵が必要なんですよ
知恵っていうのは大したことではないんですよ
この貪瞋痴で見ないで
そのまんまで余計な判断しないでいれば知恵なんです
例えば Aさんが悪い人やと言われる
あ そうですか だったらもう彼と商売をやめましょうと
もう判断して決めつけて終わっちゃう
それが無知なんです 知恵というのは何も考えないこと
Aさんが悪い人ですよと言ったら
この人がAさんが悪い人ですよと言っています
で終わり 何も判断しない
それであなた聞いてますけど
聞いてますよ ちゃんと
あなたがAさんが悪い人ですよと言っているんだから
聞いてますよと 失礼ですけど
なぜ悪いと言うんでしょうかと
証拠があるんだったら言ってくださいと
それだけで大体問題は終わります
それで証拠を聞いたら
それは客観的な証拠か
本人の判断かとちゃんとわかりますからね
客観的な証拠はあっても
だからとその人を悪いということじゃなくて
それはちゃんと調べてみなくちゃいけないんだと
だから 情報は情報だけで止まってもらう
その楽な生き方は知恵の生き方なんです
そこで仏教は この忍耐という言葉がよく使います
忍耐はおそらくパーリ語でKhantiだと思います
Khantiというのはこのサンスクリット語でKṣāntiと言うんですよ
で ヒンドゥー教の人々があの挨拶する時でも
あの"Kṣānti" "Kṣānti"と言うんですよ
Kṣānti･･･いろいろちょっと言語に行っちゃうと
ちょっともうややこしくなります
ぴったし似てはないんですけど
SantiとŚānti
別な言葉ですけどKṣāntiというまた違う言葉があります
パーリ語でKhantiというのはそのKṣāntiなんで
サンスクリット語でŚāntiはSantiになります
Khantiって忍耐って何でしょうかね
これは平和ですよ 心の
我慢には似ていますけど
平和ということなんです
すごいちょっと機能が違うんです
よくお釈迦様は比丘たちに我々に言うのは
忍耐しなさいよと 何を？例えば寒い時
暑い時とかね もう蚊がいっぱいいる時とか
虫に刺されたりとかね
お腹 ご飯がもらえなかった時とかね
人にいろいろ批判されたり
非難されたりするとかとかね
忍耐しなさいよ ということは
我慢しろということではなくて
平和でいなさいよと だからSantiっていうのは
人に褒めてもらうと舞い上がることもよくない
心に波が生まれるんですよ
舞い上がっちゃうと物事見えなくなっちゃうんですね
智慧が消えちゃうんです
だからあんまり舞い上がらない
平和でいる それで悪いことに出会う場合はね
お釈迦様はすごい立派な例えなんですよ
すごい寒さ 激しい寒さに出会うとかね
激しい暑さに出会うとか
いろいろ虫に刺されるとかね
瞑想できるところじゃないんですね
きつくて その時も  あぁ嫌だ
なんでこんなことになるんでしょうか
瞑想もできないんではないかとか
そうやってイラだち作っちゃうと平和が消えちゃうんですね
だから この我々生きている上でいろいろトラブルには出会います
いつでも落ち着いていることは忍耐なんです
楽しいんだからと山を登っても
そこで遭難してしまうということもあり得る
その時 あぁ どうでしょうか
大変だと言って暴れ回っちゃうと
怯え倒しちゃうと死んじゃいますから
落ち着いて  そんなことがあるんだと
落ち着いていると 次にどうするべきでしょうか
という道が見えてくる
だからŚāntiというのはそういうこと
これ すごい立派な人にしかできないことなんですね
褒めても舞い上がらない
けなされても機嫌が悪くしない生き方
昔のお坊さんたち 托鉢して生活していたんだから
ご飯もらったら なんのことなく
今日はよかった 今日は運が
なんて言いますか 今日はツイてるんだとかね
そんなもう俗人の言葉は話しません
なんのことなく これは召し上がる
次の日行ったら何もないと
言ったら なんのことなく帰る
こんなお腹が空いても1日1食なのに
どうしよう どうしようと
それはないんです
ある日 お釈迦様はある村に托鉢に行ったんですよ
そこで エピソードはこうなっているんです
マーラが仏教の邪魔する悪神がいるんですね
もう悪魔という意味というよりも
悪い神ですよ で かなり仏教に対しても反発する
来て この人々に乗り移って 托鉢に何もお布施しなかったんです
お釈迦様は鉢を洗って村に入ったんだけど
村に入って1つ回って何もない
それで洗ったまんまで戻ってくるんですね
戻ってくるで お釈迦様に直接
この神に喋られますからね
お釈迦様にこう言うんですね
あの人々は忙しかったんだよと
あなたが托鉢した時は
今はちゃんと料理もできています
もう一度行けば結構ご馳走いただけますよと
言ったらマーラに叱るんです
お釈迦様は ブッダがね
もう2回行くと思いますか？と
ご飯をもらうために もう1回行ってみますとかね
ないんだと ご飯があってもなくても
私には別に何の問題もないんだよと
お前みたいな欲に溺れている人ではないんだよというふうに答えるんですよ
二度とまた托鉢に行かなかったんです
だから何も思ってないんです
その日はもう食事はなしと
だからそれが仏教でいう忍耐です
それが最高の修行でありますよ
だから簡単にみんなに実践できます
いろいろ 例えば外はすごいうるさいとかね
夜寝て寝ている時って
誰かが騒音出してね オートバイでも走っていたりとかね
その時はイラ立ったりとかね
しないで 心の平和を守る
何かいいことあったんだからって舞い上がっちゃってね
もう我を忘れるのではなくて
心の平和を保つ それが忍耐なんです
次の言葉はこのViriyaだと思います
努力っていうのは Viriyaっていうのは怠けの反対なんですよ
怠けの反対 怠けって何でしょうか
怠けにパーリ語で 名詞にしちゃうとālasyaṃになりますけどね
またいろいろ格変化はありますからね
有名なpamādaという言葉もあります
ālasyaṃは怠けpamādaっていうのは
この何でしたっけ･･･放逸
そちらの反対で努力という
あの前の説明で そこら辺にはもう一応なぜ努力しなくちゃいけないかっていうことをね
pamāda この怠ける人が何するんでしょうかね
怠けて　怠けるってことは
何もやってないってことなんですね
でも我々は時間に追われているでしょうに
時間足らないでしょうに
その上怠けると とんでもない結果になるんです
この努力ってどういうことかと
この時間はっていうのは
ずっと止まることなく変わっていくんです
自分の寿命も止まることなく変わっていくんです
周りの情報も止まることなく変わっていくんです
だから落ち着いていられないんです
その瞬間瞬間でやるべきことをやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから掃除する時間来たら
そのすぐ掃除をすること
でないと後で大変なストレス溜まることになります
これも人生の失敗の一つなんですよ
例えば やるべきことを後回しにするでしょ
後でしても意味がないんです
なぜならば 時間変わっていくんだから
例えば確定申告は13日になっている
その日で出さなくちゃいけない
後にしますと言って
もう25日に行く もう遅いでしょうに
ですから 後回しは成り立たないんです
お腹が空いたらご飯を食べるんであって
明日の分まで今日食べるということは成り立たないんです
人間が この時間と物事の変化ということを全然気にしない
よく私にも言うんでしょう
日本人というのはあなた方と違ってちゃんと時間に厳密だよとかね
私は冗談言ってほしくないという立場ですけどね
時計に追われているだけで
結局は徹底的に怠けているんですけど
それが時計見て追われていることじゃなくて
それがストレスでしょうに
その瞬間でその瞬間で やるべきことをその瞬間でやらなくちゃいけないんです
私の場合は こちらに来る途中で車に跳ねられてでも
足でも折ったならば 私はそのまま病院に行くんであって
こちらは来ません いくら待っていたっても
やっぱり物事というのはそんなもんで
そんな時計に合わせてやれると できないんですよ
何が起こるかわからないんです
その場でそれを処理しておかないと
明日はダメです
今日 コンビニから弁当買ってきたら
今日は時間ないんだから
じゃあ明後日ぐらい食べましょうと
ダメです その時間でそれ食べなくちゃいけないんです
物事っていうのはそういうことで
我々は怠けちゃう 後回しにする
そうすると やるべきことをやってないことになる
それで人生そのものが不幸になってしまう
子供を叱るべき瞬間で叱らないと
後でもう大変な不幸になるんです
どんなものにでもぴったし時間
今の瞬間だよと だから人生っていうのは
やっぱりボールが向こうから出しちゃうと
ゆっくりじゃあ捕まってみようかなっていうか
捕まりませんでしょうに
そのボールが自分のところに来る瞬間があるんですよ
その瞬間で手がちゃんとそちらにあってほしいんですよ
そうするとボールをキャッチできるんです
それを忘れるなよと 先に手を出して取ったぞといっても
ボールは後から来るんだったら取られていないし
あるいはほんの瞬間でも遅くなったら取るんだけど
もう行ってるんです ボールが
それが宇宙の法則であって
どうにもならない こちらも変わっていくし
物事も変わっていくんです
ですから この瞬間を失うなよと
それはパーリ語でこう言うんです
Khanaṃ その瞬間 māっていうのは流れっていうこと
vo あなた方は　upaccagāっていうのは失うこと
その流れと それが努力ということなんです
別に踏ん張るということでもないんです
常に目が覚めていること
皆様にこのヴィパッサナー瞑想を通して教えているのは その努力なんです
瞬間瞬間ちゃんと取っておけと
後回しにするなよと
仏教ではこの大変 このĀrambhatha nikkamathaという
もうすごい努力に関わる言葉があります
ブッダにしたっても
ブッダが45年間しか説法しなかったし
その瞬間でちゃんと覚えて帰れと
後で聞きますと言ったら
誰が死ぬかわからないんですよ
だから仏教の努力というのも大変いいことで
損はしません 例えば 今私は喋ってますけど
その時間で他のことをできません
だからせんべい食べたい気持ちはあるかもしれませんだけど
ちょっと無理ですから
そんな余計なことを考えないで
この時間で話をじっと聞いておくと
もう儲かったことなんですよ
損はしていないんです
それが努力というんです
2キロしか歩けない人が4キロを歩くということを努力と言うのは
あれはバカと言うんです
足も弱いのに 腰も弱いのに
心臓も弱いのに 山を登るんだったら
さすが素晴らしい努力家と言わない
私は言わない とんでもないアホやと
それが努力とは言わないんです
努力っていうのは 講演の間では講演を聞く
終わったらじーっと また終わっても待っている必要ないんですよ
終わったらわいわいと言いたいことを言ったり
もうそれはその時 話終わったらじーっと静かにいたっても
それまたおかしいんでしょうに
逆に話しゃべっている時で
いちいちごちゃごちゃ喋っちゃうと
それまた行儀が悪くておかしいでしょうに
そうすると人生は損します
成功できません だから
その1秒で その1分で やるべきことをやっておきなさいよというブッダの教え
努力っていうのはそういうことなんです
じゃあそこで話を終了いたしますけど
最後にこの幸せ 幸福って何でしょうか
っていうのはね 幸せっていうのは
本当にこの美味しいものを食べることでもないし
たくさんのお金があることでもないし
この体をイジることじゃないんです
幸せっていうのは心の状態なんです
心で充実感が出てくるかと
おにぎり食べても 高級レストランで 10万円のディナーを食べてもどうでもいいんですよ
あなたの心がそれで充実感 感じるか感じないかと
だからブッダと弟子たちがもう人が捨てた食べ物でも食べて
木の下で寝て 私こそ幸せやと言っていたんだから
なぜならば 瞬間瞬間の充実感を感じながら
貪瞋痴がない生き方していたからなんです
この体を楽しめることはものすごく退屈になるんです
みんなわかってないだけやと思います
映画見るのは楽しい 音楽聴くのは楽しいと
あれは勘違いであって
よく聞いてみてください
退屈になるんです ストレス溜まるんですよ
映画見るのは楽しいんだけど
ポップコーンやらね いっぱい持って行って
それパクパク食べて もうカロリーもいっぱい食べて溜まってしまっちゃうんです
楽しいんだったらそれ見て楽しんでほしいんだけど
結局ストレス溜まるんですよ
音楽でも同じことで 食べることも同じことで
かなりストレス溜まっちゃう
だからこの五欲を楽しむ
五欲に溺れることが不幸なんです
充実感 感じられるか それがやったぞという気持ちなんですよ
映画見に行っても ちゃんと映画を見る
ちゃんとそれを理解もする
そうすると 何を見たかも知ってるし
監督が何言いたかったいたんでしょうか
知ってるし 映画のからくりもちゃんと知ってるし
いろいろ工夫やら技術やらね
各映画で使っているでしょうに
歴史的な映画だったら
本当に歴史はそのまま語っているか
あるいはどこまで新しく変えているかとか
そこまでも知っているし
そうすると 払ったいくらぐらいですかね
わかりません   1,200円は無駄でなくなっちゃいますよ
それでポップコーン食べるわ
コーヒー飲むわ トイレに走っていくわ
また誰かと隣の人としゃべるわと
見てないんですね  1,300円の損
時間の無駄
ですから それで見たら 見たぞという充実感が出てきます
それがこの瞬間瞬間 ちゃんと生きている時だけ成り立つものなんです
そういうふうに 我々みんな
この今の瞬間は無駄にしないで
きちんと単純で生きているということで
心に充実感が得られると
それがブッダが教える幸福だよと
すべてやったぞと もうやることもうないんだぞというのは
お釈迦様おっしゃっている涅槃という究極的な解脱であります
そこら辺で話を終了したいと思います
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]